[Music]
from the fiery blast of a Saturn rocket
to those four steps on the lunar surface
images from America's space program are
etched in our collective memory but
along with those sights there are the
sounds the words that also tell this
remarkable story of human achievements
with a story in Douglas Brinkley and CBS
News space analyst bill Harwood here's a
look back at some of the most memorable
[Applause]
tranquility we copy on the ground
you got a bunch of guys about to turn
blue we're breathing again thanks a lot
we may be remembered our whole
generation is the first one that figured
out how to break the shackles of Earth
[Music]
the big moment is may 25th 1961 when
John F Kennedy in front of a joint
session of Congress says I believe that
this nation should commit itself to
achieving the goal before this decade is
out of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to the earth
everybody in NASA said are you kidding
me we have zero technology to do such a
thing
this was Cold War conflict it was a
battle with the Russians you know they'd
beat us into space with the first
satellite Sputnik in 1957 they put the
first human in space Yuri Gagarin in
1961 just five days after Yuri Gagarin
launched into space was the Bay of Pigs
failure the invasion of Cuba that was
such a an embarrassing fiasco for a
young president John F Kennedy not
because they are easy but because he was
looking for something he could come up
with a plan that America could attach to
could follow and execute that they would
have some chance of winning in the long
run only Alan Shepard the first mercury
astronaut had been into space on a
suborbital flight he didn't even get to
orbit when John Glenn came along that
was a different ballgame
turning around oh that mr. fender okay
we did spacewalking
we had to get very close to the moon to
check out carefully where the proper
landing site the Sea of Tranquility
would be then mercury missions were all
must watched TV a Gemini fell off a
little bit we have a Vietnam War women
Johnson Medicaid and Medicare
counterculture and civil rights and the
agenda got crowded but then came the
Apollo disaster of Apollo 1 it was
during a ground test at the launch pad
at Cape Canaveral the three crew members
Gus Grissom ed white and Roger Chaffee
were strapped into their Apollo capsule
the door was sealed in place they had a
100% oxygen environment in there of
course and any spark in that sort of
environment would be catastrophic and at
some point during that test there was a
spark a conflagration to prove perished
within seconds it was a tremendous
setback to NASA of course NASA was
determined to meet the goal and they
kept at it of course lost in Apollo 7
mission you know within about a year and
a half of the of the fire the missions
were ramping up to Apollo 11 I generated
quite a bit of news back in 1968 the
first Saturn 5 that anyone wrote on the
Apollo 8 mission went all the way to the
moon orbited the moon and on Christmas
Eve Frank Borman and his crewmates radio
down chapters of Genesis they read aloud
as they orbited the moon
the key thing about Apollo 11 it's about
eight days of drama but I think one of
the most interesting moments is when
they're sitting there on the moon they
have landed what a strange feeling to be
the only two people on an entire moon
with earth in the distance how does one
even reconstruct such a feeling of
something so ethereal they stayed within
the vicinity of their spacecraft
Armstrong collected a little bit of soil
in case they had to get on and and leave
quickly and then of course the
ceremonial aspect of planning the
American flag on the moon neither
Armstrong Aldrin were that keen on the
photography element of it but NASA knew
that people would want this sort of
photographs from the moon and thank
goodness they did because of anything
stirs the imagination it's that
photographic evidence of being on the
moon nASA says tomater the TV audience
was around 500 million viewers I think
it is the greatest event in human
history you can look at what the program
cost and you can certainly wonder if
that was the best use of taxpayer money
and certainly there were people who
thought it wasn't Congress itself is not
providing funds to deal with the
problems of poverty what you see here
the big question that you know people
often ask is was it worth 25 billion
dollars to go to the moon that's about a
hundred and eighty billion today the
answer of why you give yes is the
spin-off technology out of that comes
smaller computers GPS cat scan MRI heart
defibrillators kidney dialysis machines
suits for fire fighters that don't burn
many people think Apollo 11 NASA gave
birth to Silicon Valley and the computer
world of today it did
it's very primitive Paulo Lebanon
compared to what we can do today and so
I'll be curious on the 50th anniversary
and hopeful that America makes a
commitment to the return to the moon in
earnest with a deadline the way that
Kennedy gave us one amazing he's
fascinating that produced by producer
vidya saying that
cheers to her that is the best she and
we thank Douglas Brinkley and bill
Harwood as well for their perspective
it's just interesting to think about
that one moment and how important was
for so many people but then what had led
to and the other technology that was
created because of it and is still being
created I mean the notion that Silicon
Valley is a result to a certain extent
of that moon landing and the research
that took place that entangle of it